A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. On the night of Friday, October 3, 2008, Canadian couple Trevor and Marissa were out walking their dog in the quiet suburban district of Mill Woods in Edmonton South.
一股清新的水流将触及你的心灵深处。那些蔚蓝的巨浪可以推动你向前，也可以安抚你的心。从密歇根州的一个海岸到另一个海岸。只需感受当下的水流。让那些广阔的湖泊、河流和溪流创造永恒的回忆。马上纵身跃入，让纯净的密歇根之水洗涤你。在 Michigan.org 保持新鲜感。2008年10月3日星期五晚上，一对加拿大夫妇特雷弗（Trevor）和玛丽莎（Marissa）正在埃德蒙顿南部米尔伍兹（Mill Woods）安静的住宅区遛狗。
Suddenly, a young, dark-haired man staggered into their path from the direction of a nearby alleyway. He was hunched over, his shirt was torn, and he had a large welt on his sweaty face. He collapsed and rolled around in what the couple thought was an overly theatrical manner, then stood up and screamed, There's a guy attacking me, he's mugging me, please help me. He cried out, that's the guy, as a second hooded man wearing a black hockey mask with gold markings emerged from the alleyway. The man tapped his mask as though to adjust it, then slipped behind a fence. He peered over the top and called out to the injured man, come on Frank, come back. Though he sounded a lot harder than friendly, Trevor and Marissa felt uneasy.
突然，一个年轻、黑发的男子从附近一条小巷的方向踉跄着闯入他们的视线。他驼着背，衬衫撕破了，汗津津的脸上有一个大肿块。他倒地并打着滚，在夫妇俩看来，他的动作未免有些太戏剧化了，接着他站起身大喊：“有个家伙在袭击我，他在抢劫我，请帮帮我。”他大喊道：“就是那个家伙，”与此同时，第二个戴着带有金色斑纹的黑色曲棍球面具的连帽男子从巷子里走了出来。那名男子拍了拍面具，仿佛在调整它，然后溜到篱笆后面。他探出头朝受伤的男子喊道：“来吧，弗兰克，回来吧。”尽管他的语气听起来一点也不友好，但特雷弗和玛丽莎还是感到一阵不安。
Suspecting this scenario was a setup to mug them, the couple hurried away as the dishevelled stranger cried out, Can you at least help me get to my car? Trevor wanted to help, but couldn't shake his suspicion that it was a trap. He and Marissa rushed home where they called the police. Officers were dispatched to the alleyway, but the two men were gone and nothing seemed out of the ordinary. They monitored the situation over the coming days, but received a note word from the alleged victim, or further sightings of the assailant in the hockey mask. 38-year-old Johnny Altinger lived alone in his small apartment in Edmonton,
这对夫妇怀疑这出戏是抢劫他们的圈套，于是匆忙走开，而那个衣衫褴褛的陌生人则大喊道：“你们至少能帮我走到我的车旁吗？”特雷弗想帮忙，但心中的怀疑挥之不去，总觉得这是一个陷阱。他和玛丽莎赶忙跑回家报了警。警察被派往那条小巷，但那两个男子已经不见了，一切看起来都很正常。他们在接下来的几天里密切关注着局势，但没有收到任何来自所谓受害者的消息，也没有人再次看到戴曲棍球面具的袭击者。38岁的强尼·阿尔廷格（Johnny Altinger）独自住在埃德蒙顿的一间小公寓里，
where he was employed as a pipeline worker for oil-filled equipment manufacturer Argus Machine. His night shifts were spent in quality control, a job he neither loved nor hated, but which gave him satisfaction. Although they lived in different cities, he remained close with both his mother, Alfreda, and his older brother, Gary, and had a close-knit group of friends, some of whom stretched back to grade school. They described Johnny as good-natured, light-hearted, generous, thoughtful, quiet, and affectionate, with an optimistic outlook that he used to help others adopt a more positive attitude in their own lives. Johnny had a number of hobbies, but the two that drew most of his attention were motorbikes and computers. He owned two bikes, a Honda 500cc and a Yamaha 1200cc sport touring bike.
他在那里的油田设备制造商阿格斯机械公司（Argus Machine）担任管道工人。他的夜班工作是质量控制，这份工作他谈不上多喜欢，也谈不上讨厌，但它带给他一种满足感。尽管他们住在不同的城市，但他与母亲阿尔弗雷达（Alfreda）和哥哥加里（Gary）关系依然很近，并且有一群亲密无间的朋友，其中有些人甚至从小学起就认识了。他们将强尼描述为一个性格随和、乐观开朗、慷慨体贴、安静而深情的人，他总是带着乐观的心态，并用这种心态帮助其他人对生活采取更积极的态度。强尼有很多爱好，但最吸引他的两个是摩托车和电脑。他拥有两辆摩托车，一辆本田500cc和一辆雅马哈1200cc运动旅行摩托车。
His free time was spent going on rides, playing paintball, dabbling in new-age spirituality, and enjoying the music of Elton John. At age 12, Johnny begged his mother to buy him a Commodore 64, an 8-bit home computer, sparking what would become a lifelong passion. From then on, he was an early adopter of computing tech, constantly upgrading his systems through the various hardware and software iterations. He was always willing to help out his less tech-savvy friends and family, with his brother Gary Ultinger stating, Countless times he would sacrifice his own responsibilities to rescue me by word-processing term papers, essays, and other important assignments while I was attending university. I owe much of my academic success to John. Johnny made many online friends who eventually became his friends in real life too, and by his 30s he was participating in online dating. He joined the two most popular free sites at the time, Plenty of Fish and Lava Life, and went on several dates of varying success, while remaining optimistic that he'd find his perfect match someday.
他的空闲时间都用来骑车、玩彩弹射击、涉足新时代灵性，以及欣赏埃尔顿·约翰（Elton John）的音乐。12岁时，强尼恳求母亲给他买一台康道尔64（Commodore 64）8位家用电脑，这激发了他终生的热情。从那时起，他便成了计算技术的早期使用者，通过各种硬件和软件的迭代不断升级他的系统。他总是乐于帮助那些对技术不太懂的朋友和家人，他的哥哥加里·阿尔廷格（Gary Ultinger）表示：“无数次，他为了帮我摆脱困境而牺牲自己的时间，帮我用文字处理机完成学期论文、散文和其他重要作业，当时我正在上大学。我的大部分学术成功都要归功于约翰。”强尼结交了许多网友，他们最终也成为了他现实生活中的朋友。到了30多岁时，他开始参与在线约会。他加入了当时最受欢迎的两个免费交友网站——Plenty of Fish和Lava Life，并约会了几次，结果各不相同，但他依然乐观地认为自己总有一天会找到真爱。
On Plenty of Fish, Johnny connected with a 35-year-old woman named Jen, who sought fun times. Her profile pictures depicted an attractive woman in a bikini, although Johnny was aware that photos could be misleading. Banta between the pair indicated they were a good match, and they organised the date for the night of Friday, October 10, 2008. Jen didn't provide a street address for their meet-up, instead giving precise, turn-by-turn directions to a set location a 10-minute drive away from Johnny's apartment. She had written, Although this sounds exciting, I have to make sure you're not some kind of weirdo, and so far you seem to be fairly well put together, but anyone can lie online. Jen instructed Johnny to park in the driveway that looks like a forest, and sneak through a partially open garage door, making sure to press a button to close it behind him. She explained that a blanket would be spread out on the floor, as a friend was using the space as a workshop that weekend.
在 Plenty of Fish 上，强尼结识了一位35岁名叫简（Jen）的女子，她寻求的是有趣的时光。她的个人资料照片显示这是一个颇具吸引力的比基尼女郎，尽管强尼也知道照片可能会具有欺骗性。两人之间的网聊表明他们非常般配，于是他们将约会时间定在2008年10月10日星期五晚上。简没有提供见面地点的街道地址，而是给出了精确的、具体的路线指引，目的地是距离强尼公寓车程10分钟的一个地方。她写道：“虽然这听起来很刺激，但我必须确保你不是什么怪人，到目前为止你看起来还算靠谱，但网上的任何人都可以撒谎。”简指示强尼将车停在“看起来像森林”的车道上，然后悄悄穿过一扇半开的车库门，并务必按一下按钮将门在身后关上。她解释说，地板上会铺一条毯子，因为周末有朋友把这个空间当成车间使用。
By following her directions, Jen would be able to see Johnny before letting him into the house. Quote, Maybe this is paranoid on my part, but I have to look after myself. My first instincts about people are never wrong, and I know to trust them. I want to play very much, but I have to be cautious, as I'm sure you can understand. If you're okay with this, let me know. If not, we'll have to miss each other. On a lighter note though, if we really get on, you said you had four days off. How long can I keep you for if I choose?
按照她的路线走，简就能在让强尼进屋之前先看到他。她说：“也许这算是我多疑，但我必须照顾好自己。我对人的第一直觉从来没有错，我知道应该相信它们。我非常想玩得开心，但我必须谨慎，我相信你能理解。如果你能接受这一点，请告诉我。如果不行，那我们就只能失之交臂了。不过轻松一点说，如果我们真的很合得来，你说你有四天假。如果我选择的话，我可以留你多久？”
Maybe you should pack for a few days. Shortly before he left for his date, Johnny phoned his longtime trusted friend, Dale Smith. Dale thought the messages from Jen were suspicious, and joked that Johnny should call him once he got there to let him know he was safe. When Johnny arrived at the garage a short time later, he was met by a friendly and jovial man who explained he was using the location to direct films. He showed Johnny around the set where he was currently making a movie about a serial killer and let him hold a fake gun that was among various prop weapons on a metal table. The man told Johnny that Jen had been held up in traffic and didn't know what time she would be back. Disappointed, Johnny headed home and called Dale, recounting the failed date in his typical light-hearted manner. Shortly after Johnny hung up, Dale received an email message from his friend that read,
“也许你应该收拾好几天的行李。”在动身去约会之前不久，强尼给他的长期密友戴尔·史密斯（Dale Smith）打了电话。戴尔觉得来自简的信息很可疑，并开玩笑说强尼一到那里就应该给他打电话报平安。不久后，当强尼到达车库时，一位热情开朗的男子接待了他，该男子解释说他正在这里利用这个地点指导拍电影。他带强尼参观了目前正在拍摄一部关于连环杀手的电影的片场，并让强尼拿了一把金属桌上各种道具武器中的假枪。这名男子告诉强尼，简在路上堵车了，不知道几点才能回来。强尼感到很失望，于是回了家并给戴尔打电话，用他一贯轻松的语气讲述了这次失败的约会。强尼挂断电话后不久，戴尔收到了他朋友发来的一封电子邮件，上面写着：
She's home now, I'm heading over again. Eager to hear the outcome of the date, Dale left numerous messages for Johnny on voicemail and text, but he didn't respond to any. Dale hoped that it had gone better than expected, and his friend just didn't have time to reply. By Sunday, his enthusiasm turned to concern when Johnny failed to meet for a scheduled motorbike lesson. Friends often quipped that Johnny was so reliable you could set your watch by him, and it was completely out of character for him to simply not show up without explanation. On Monday morning, Dale finally received an email from Johnny that read, I've met an extraordinary woman named Jen who was offered to take me on a nice long tropical vacation.
她现在到家了，我要再过去一趟。急切地想要知道约会结果的戴尔给强尼留了无数个语音和短信留言，但强尼都没有回复。戴尔希望约会进展得比预期还要顺利，而他的朋友只是没有时间回复。到了星期天，当强尼没有按计划去上摩托车课时，他的热情变成了担忧。朋友们经常开玩笑说强尼是个极守信用的人，甚至可以对照他的手表来调时，而他不作任何解释就无故爽约，这完全不符合他的性格。周一早上，戴尔终于收到强尼发来的一封电子邮件，上面写道：“我遇到了一位非凡的女性，名叫简，她主动提出带我去度一次美好的热带长假。”
We'll be staying in her winter home in Costa Rica, phone number to follow soon. I won't be in town until December 10, but I will be checking my email periodically. Dale was stunned. Johnny would never skip work to take an impromptu holiday, and he didn't like warm destinations, once returning from a trip to Hawaii complaining of the heat. Dale knew if Johnny was truly leaving, it would take a few minutes to call, if only to ask Dale to store his beloved motorbikes. Furthermore, Johnny never signed off emails with his name,
我们将在她在哥斯达黎加的冬季度假屋里住一段时间，电话号码稍后会发给你。我直到12月10日才会回城，但我会定期查看电子邮件。戴尔惊呆了。强尼绝不会为了来一场说走就走的旅行而旷工，而且他不喜欢温暖的目的地，有一次从夏威夷旅行回来时还在抱怨天气太热。戴尔知道，如果强尼真的是要离开，至少会花几分钟打个电话，哪怕只是请戴尔帮忙照看他深爱的摩托车。此外，强尼在发邮件时从不用自己的名字落款，
preferring to finish with a wisecrack about his friend. Believing Johnny did not author the message, Dale tested the sender by responding with a query, asking who would pick up Johnny's brother from the airport when he came to visit. Gary wasn't actually coming, and Johnny would know this, but Dale didn't get a reply. Other friends had also received the abrupt farewell email from Johnny, each replied asking him to get in touch, but none heard back. Like Dale, one was suspicious as to who had sent the email, as Johnny usually called her sunshine, and the message was missing his telltale signs,
而是喜欢用一句关于他朋友的俏皮话来结尾。戴尔坚信这条信息不是强尼写的，于是他用一个问题来测试发件人，询问当强尼的哥哥来探访时，谁会去机场接他。加里实际上并没有来，强尼也知道这一点，但戴尔没有收到回复。其他朋友也收到了强尼发来的这封语气生硬的告别邮件，每个人都回信让她保持联系，但没有一个人得到回复。和戴尔一样，其中一人对是谁发送了这封邮件心存怀疑，因为强尼通常叫她“阳光”，而且这信息里缺少他标志性的特征，
including the joke or smiley face he ended their correspondence with. That same day, an update appeared on Johnny's Facebook page that read, Johnny is taking off to the Caribbean for a few months, see you all when I get back. His relationship status was also changed to, in a relationship. That evening, Johnny's boss received an email from him that read, Greetings, while I've certainly enjoyed my time at Argus, I have another offer that is just too good to pass up. So this is my notice that I will no longer be continuing my employment with your fine organization. I thank you for the opportunity, and rest assured, I would not be leaving
包括他用来结束通讯的笑话或笑脸符号。就在同一天，强尼的脸书（Facebook）主页上出现了一条更新，上面写着：“强尼要去加勒比海呆几个月了，等我回来再见大家。”他的感情状态也被改成了“恋爱中”。那天晚上，强尼的老板收到了他的一封电子邮件，上面写着：“问候，虽然我在阿格斯的工作确实很愉快，但我得到了另一个好到无法拒绝的offer。因此，在此通知各位，我将不再贵公司继续任职。感谢您给予的机会，请放心，我不会离开，”
unless this new path I've chosen was truly life altering. Thank you, John Oltinger. There was no further contact from Johnny over the following days. His boss wrote back to him, John, there are many rumors floating around about what you have run off to do. All I need to know is where to forward your last check. Good luck in your endeavors, wherever they may be. Johnny ignored the message, and his $1,500 final paycheck went uncollected.
“除非我选择的新道路真的能改变我的一生。谢谢，约翰·阿尔廷格。”在接下来的几天里，强尼没有再与任何人联系。他的老板回信写道：“约翰，关于你到底跑去干什么，外面流言四起。我只需要知道把你的最后一张薪水支票寄到哪里。祝你在新的事业中一切顺利，无论你在哪里。”强尼忽略了这条信息，他那1500美元的最后薪水支票也无人领取。
Meanwhile, his MSN messenger status changed too, I've got a one-way ticket to heaven, and I'm never coming back. And his Facebook page was updated once more to say, Johnny's wondering why anyone would leave son and surf to come home to snow and stress. Carrie Lynn Sousa was the wife of one of Johnny's friends. Although she had never met him, she decided to reach out to Johnny over Facebook in an effort to assist his friends. In a private message, she wrote,
与此同时，他的MSN聊天状态也变了：“我买了一张通往天堂的单程票，再也不会回来了。”他的脸书主页再次更新，写道：“强尼想知道为什么有人会离开阳光与冲浪，回到冰雪和压力交织的家中。”凯莉·林恩·苏萨（Carrie Lynn Sousa）是强尼的一位朋友的妻子。尽管她从未见过他，但她决定通过脸书联系强尼，以协助他的朋友们。她在一条私信中写道：
Hi John, please respond as soon as you get this, or at least call Dale. Everyone is concerned for you. Thanks, Carrie Lynn. Surprisingly, she received a prompt reply that read, No need to be worried, I'm on vacation and loving it. The internet is much easier to use than phones due to terrible reception and cost. I just need to get away for a while, and I'm with someone wonderful. I'll try to get in touch with Dale as soon as possible,
“嗨，约翰，请一看到就回复，或者至少给戴尔打个电话。大家都为你担心。谢谢，凯莉·林恩。”令她惊讶的是，她很快收到了回复，上面写着：“无需担心，我在度假，过得很开心。由于信号太差且费用高昂，互联网比电话好用得多。我只是需要离开一段时间，而且我和一个很棒的人在一起。我会尽快尝试与戴尔取得联系，”
but in the meantime, let him know I'm having the time of my life. Carrie Lynn provided Johnny with a call collect phone number he could reach Dale on, and told him to ring by 6.30pm, or they would be following up with Edmonton City Police. When the call never came, the police were alerted, but they weren't overly concerned. They accepted Johnny's explanation that he had gone on holiday with a woman he had met online. Unconvinced, Johnny's friends decided to break into his apartment to search for clues. They arrived at Johnny's four-story condo, where his motorcycle sat uncovered in the outdoor parking lot of the complex. His red Mazda 323 was missing.
“但在那之前，请告诉他我正过着我一生中最快乐的时光。”凯莉·林恩给强尼提供了一个对方付费电话号码，他可以通过这个号码联系到戴尔，并告诉他必须在晚上6:30之前打电话，否则他们将报警。当电话始终没打来时，人们报警了，但警方并没有表现出过分担忧。他们接受了强尼的解释，即他和在网上认识的一个女人去度假了。强尼的朋友们并不买账，决定破门进入他的公寓寻找线索。他们来到了强尼所在的四层公寓楼，他的摩托车没有盖车衣，就停在小区的露天停车场里。他的红色马自达323不见了。
They broke a window to gain access to Johnny's apartment, finding dirty dishes in the sink, a paintball gun resting on his unmade bed, an open CD case on the white leather couch in the lounge room. His motorcycle jacket hung over the back of a kitchen chair and his helmet on the table. The mess itself wasn't unusual, as Johnny was known to tidy up when he expected guests. Yet, the overall state of the apartment did not correlate with a person who had gone on holiday for an extended period of time. Johnny's laptop was missing, and strangely, so was his printer. In a surprise discovery, a desk drawer contained his passport, confirming he could not have gone to Costa Rica. The group returned to the Edmonton Police with the evidence they had gathered.
他们砸碎了一扇窗户以进入强尼的公寓，发现水槽里有脏盘子，一张彩弹枪放在他没有整理的床上，客厅的白色皮沙发上放着一个打开的CD盒。他的摩托车夹克挂在一把厨房椅子的靠背上，头盔放在桌子上。房间乱糟糟的这倒并不罕见，因为大家都知道强尼在预料有客人来时才会收拾房间。然而，公寓的整体状况与一个离家去外地度长假的人完全不符。强尼的笔记本电脑不见了，奇怪的是，他的打印机也不见了。令人意外的是，他们在一个抽屉里发现了他的护照，这证实他根本不可能去过哥斯达黎加。这群人带着收集到的证据回到了埃德蒙顿警察局。
Realizing the circumstances of his alleged departure didn't add up, police opened a missing persons file for Johnny Ultinger on Friday, October 17, 2008, one week after his last confirmed communications. A search for his car at the airport came up dry, and his name was absent from the passenger lists of all departing international flights. The detailed instructions Jen emailed Johnny for their first date provided the strongest lead. Detective Bill Clark was surprised to learn that Johnny had forwarded the instructions to two friends before going out, including Dale Smith, who recalled his friend saying something like, If anything happens to me, you'll know where to look. There were constant warnings to women on dating sites to exercise caution and to let someone know where they were going, but it was far less common for men to do so.
意识到他所谓的离职和离开的种种情况根本对不上号，警方于2008年10月17日星期五——即他最后一次被确认与外界联系的一周后——为强尼·阿尔廷格立案失踪人员档案。警方在机场搜寻他的汽车一无所获，所有离境国际航班的乘客名单中也没有他的名字。简在电子邮件中发给强尼的关于他们第一次约会的详细路线指引成了最强有力的线索。比尔·克拉克（Bill Clark）侦探惊讶地得知，强尼在出门前将这些路线指引转发给了两个朋友，其中包括戴尔·史密斯，戴尔回忆起他的朋友曾说过类似这样的话：“如果我出了什么事，你知道去哪儿找。” dating网站上经常对女性发出警告，提醒她们保持警惕并让别人知道她们要去哪里，但男性这样做则要少得多。
The directions led detectives to a garage in a laneway in the residential area of Mill Woods in the city's southeast. They arrived close to midnight, finding the building locked with a combination padlock. The windows were covered up, but one constable peaked through a small hole and could see a light on inside. There didn't appear to be anyone in there, and the interior was clean. They knocked on the door to their joining house, but there was no answer. An application for a search warrant was denied, as there was no evidence a crime had been committed. However, police inquiries led to Kirkside Real Estate, who confirmed the garage had been leased to Mark Twitchell, an independent filmmaker. On the evening of Saturday, October 18, police called Mark and told him there was a problem with the garage he was renting.
这些路线将侦探们引向了该市东南部米尔伍兹住宅区一条巷子里的一个车库。他们接近午夜时分抵达，发现大楼被一把密码挂锁锁上了。窗户被遮挡住了，但一名警员透过一个小孔往里看，可以看到里面亮着灯。里面似乎没有人，而且内部很干净。他们敲了敲与其相连的房子的门，但无人应答。搜查令的申请被拒绝了，因为没有证据表明发生了犯罪行为。然而，警方的调查锁定了科克斯ide房地产公司（Kirkside Real Estate），该公司证实该车库已经租给了独立电影制作人马克·特维特切尔（Mark Twitchell）。10月18日星期六晚上，警方打电话给马克，告诉他他租的车库出了点问题。
The director readily agreed to come and open it up. At around 11.30pm, a maroon-coloured Pontiac Grand AM sedan pulled up outside the garage and Mark Twitchell emerged. He was agitated as he had to pull over twice while on his way over to answer calls from Kirkside Real Estate, from which he surmised that someone had been using the garage without his knowledge and left the lights on. As Mark went to let the police into the building, he expressed surprise at the padlock on the door, explaining it was different from the one he'd been using. His combination padlock was silver on the outside with a black plastic dial in the centre, but this one was pure metal. Mark said he didn't know the combination and allowed officers to break it off.
这位导演爽快地答应过来打开它。晚上11点半左右，一辆褐红色的庞蒂亚克大阿姆（Pontiac Grand AM）轿车停在车库外，马克·特维特切尔从车里走了出来。他显得有些心神不宁，因为在赶来接听科克斯ide房地产公司电话的路上，他不得不把车停下两次，他由此推测有人在不知情的情况下使用了车库并把灯开着了。当马克去给警察开门时，他对外面的挂锁表现出惊讶，解释说这与他一直使用的锁不同。他的密码挂锁外面是银色的，中间有一个黑色的塑料拨盘，但这把锁是纯金属的。马克说他不知道密码，并允许警员将其砸断。
Mark explained that he rented the garage for $175 a month. The residential space was rented to temporary foreign workers while someone else lived in the basement. Mark didn't have any contact with the other people in the building. As they entered the garage, a strong smell lingered inside indicating something had recently been burned in there. The odor emanated from an oil drum in one corner that had scorch marks and contained charred remains. Mark said he ordered the barrel to use as a garbage can and it had not been scorched when he had last seen it. He also noted that several things were out of place. Most of his roll of duct tape had been used, all his garbage bags were gone and an unopened bottle of cleaner was now half empty.
马克解释说，他以每月175美元的价格租下了这个车库。住宅区租给了临时外国劳工，而地下室则住着另一个人。马克与大楼里的其他人没有任何接触。当他们进入车库时，里面弥漫着一股浓烈的气味，表明不久前里面有什么东西被烧过。这股气味散发自角落里的一个油桶，桶上有烧焦的痕迹，里面装着烧焦的残骸。马克说他订购这个桶是打算当垃圾桶用的，他上次看到它时并没有被烧焦。他还注意到有几样东西摆放得不对劲。他的一大卷强力胶带大部分都用完了，所有的垃圾袋都不见了，一瓶未开封的清洁剂现在也用了一半。
All the windows were covered from the inside and when the roller doors were closed it was impossible to see in. Mark explained that in late September he had filmed a scene for his short psychological thriller about a serial killer titled House of Cards. As it occurred at night time, he had to block out the daylight that poured into the building. There were a few red spatters about the garage, which Mark clarified were remnants of fake blood. The attending officers decided to call their staff sergeant and while waiting, Mark Twitchell chatted with Constable Christopher Maxwell in a police car preparing his written statement. There was a pleasant conversation, mostly centred on Mark's billmaking and interest in the Star Wars movie franchise. When asked if he would be willing to come back to the station to answer some questions, Mark agreed. It was around 3.30am when Detective Mike Tabla interviewed Mark Twitchell.
所有的窗户都从内部被遮挡起来了，当卷帘门关上时，里面什么也看。马克解释说，在9月下旬，他为他的微型心理惊悚片《纸牌屋》（House of Cards）拍摄了一个场景，片名暂定为《纸牌屋》。由于故事发生在夜间，他必须挡住射入大楼的日光。车库里有一些红色的血迹斑点，马克澄清说那是假血的残留物。出警的警员决定呼叫他们的值班中士，在等待期间，马克·特维特切尔坐在警车里与克里斯托弗·麦克斯韦（Christopher Maxwell）警员闲聊，同时准备他的书面供词。这是一次愉快的谈话，主要围绕马克的电影制作以及他对《星球大战》电影系列的兴趣展开。当被问及是否愿意回警局回答一些问题时，马克爽快地答应了。大约凌晨3点30分，迈克·塔布拉（Mike Tabla）侦探对马克·特维特切尔进行了讯问。
He was forthcoming and helpful, though seemed more interested in talking about his film career. He shared how he'd lined up A-list actors and the co-producer who worked on the 2001 Heist film Ocean's 11 for an upcoming comedy and discussed his plans to submit House of Cards to festivals or pitch it to investors in the hopes they would fund a feature-length version or television series. He described the scene in the garage, detailing how the production crew had made large quantities of fake blood using corn syrup and food dye, creating a realistic but messy result. Detective Tabla pointed out the coincidence that Mark was filming a serial killer movie in the very place a man had disappeared from. Mark agreed, stating, I got this weird chill because it just doesn't sit right, so the first thing I start asking myself is, who knows about what we do there and what our schedule looks like. Mark provided a list of people who had worked on House of Cards and others who had accessed the garage.
他态度坦率、乐于助人，尽管他似乎对谈论自己的电影生涯更感兴趣。他分享了他是如何请到一线演员以及曾参与2001年劫案电影《十一罗汉》（Ocean's 11）的联合制片人来制作一部即将上映的喜剧，并讨论了他计划将《纸牌屋》送去电影节参展，或者向投资者推销以期获得资金来拍摄长片版或电视剧的计划。他描述了车库里的那个场景，详细讲述了制作团队如何用玉米糖浆和食用色素制作大量的假血，从而创造出逼真但凌乱的效果。塔布拉侦探指出，马克在一个男子失踪的地方拍摄一部连环杀人电影，这未免太巧合了。马克表示赞同，并说道：“我感到一阵莫名的寒意，因为这感觉太不对劲了，所以我脑子里首先浮现的问题是，谁知道我们在那里做什么以及我们的拍摄日程是什么样的？”马克提供了一份曾参与《纸牌屋》制作的人员名单以及其他可以进入该车库的人员名单。
He said the last time he had been there was Friday, October 10, the day Johnny Altinger's friends last confirmed contact with the missing man. When asked if he knew of someone called Johnny Altinger, Mark was certain he had never heard the name. The detective provided details about Johnny's last known activity and how he had gone to the garage to meet Jen, but instead encountered a man working on a film. Mark appeared baffled, claiming not to know anybody by the name of Jen. A rudimentary background check revealed that Mark Twitchell came from a good home and had no history of violence or criminality, although there was an old bankruptcy that would soon be discharged. After the lengthy interview, Mark was released with instructions to contact police if he recalled anything that may assist in their search for Johnny Altinger. The next day, Detective Tabla received a three-page email from Mark Twitchell, in which he recalled several strange occurrences he believed might be related to their investigation. Weeks earlier, Mark's car was broken into while he was at a show with a friend named Joss, who had worked odd production jobs on House of Cards and designed the film's website.
他说他最后一次去那里是在10月10日星期五，也就是强尼·阿尔廷格的朋友们最后一次确认与这位失踪男子取得联系的日子。当被问及是否认识一个叫强尼·阿尔廷格的人时，马克坚称他从未听过这个名字。侦探向他提供了强尼最后已知的活动细节，以及他是如何去车库见简，却遇到一个在拍电影的人的经过。马克显得十分困惑，坚称不认识任何叫简的人。初步背景调查显示，马克·特维特切尔出身于一个良好的家庭，没有暴力或犯罪前科，不过他有一宗即将解除的旧破产记录。经过漫长的讯问后，马克被释放，并被指示如果想起任何可能协助搜寻强尼·阿尔廷格的事情，请与警方联系。第二天，塔布拉侦探收到了一封来自马克·特维特切尔的三页电子邮件，他在邮件中回忆了几件他认为可能与他们的调查有关的奇异事件。几周前，马克和一位名叫乔斯（Joss）的朋友去看演出时，马克的车被砸了。乔斯曾在《纸牌屋》中做过零散的制作工作，并设计了该片的网站。
The offender stole Mark's sunglasses, the loose cash kept in the cup holder, and a bunch of receipts. One was for financial services company Western Union and featured Mark's residential address, while two others related to the garage and listed its address. Then, on the night of Sunday, October 12, Mark returned home after visiting his in-laws to find the front door to his home unlocked. He didn't notice anything missing or any signs of an intruder and chalked it up to paranoia and fatigue. On Wednesday, October 15, Mark had just driven to a petrol station to fill up a jerry can and had pulled over to answer a call when a stranger tapped on his window. The Caucasian man was around 6 feet 2 inches tall, medium-built, with black mid-length hair. Mark rolled down his window and the man asked if he'd like to buy his car, a red Mazda 323, as he was set to receive a brand new BMW from a sugar mama he had hooked up with. The man wanted to get rid of his Mazda before taking off on an all-expenses paid vacation and offered to sell it to Mark for whatever cash he had on him.
罪犯偷走了马克的太阳镜、放在杯架里的零钱以及一叠收据。其中一张是金融服务公司西联汇款（Western Union）的，上面有马克的住宅地址，另外两张与车库有关，上面列出了车库的地址。接着，在10月12日星期日晚上，马克拜访完岳父母家回到家里，发现前门没有锁。他没有发现任何东西丢失或有入侵的迹象，便把这归咎于多疑和疲劳。10月15日星期三，马克刚刚开车去加油站给一个汽油桶加油，随后把车停在路边接电话，这时一个陌生人敲了他的车窗。这个白人男子身高约6英尺2英寸（约1.88米），中等身材，留着黑色中长发。马克摇下车窗，那男子问他是否想买他的车——一辆红色的马自达323，因为他准备从一个包养他的富婆那里拿到一辆崭新的宝马。这男子想在踏上一场费用全包的假期前把他的马自达脱手，并提出只要马克身上有多少现金就把车卖给他。
Mark replied that he only had $40 and was surprised when the man accepted the small payment. Although suspicious, Mark permitted the man to follow him to the garage. He described in the email to Detective Tabla, quote, He's even killed disposition all but disappeared when we got to the garage and I was getting a weird vibe from him. The man was obviously keen to get going, handing Mark the Mazda's keys, registration and insurance before taking off. Mark quickly realized the car had a manual transmission, which he didn't know how to operate, and had his friend Joss collect the Mazda and store it. Mark finished up his email, writing, I don't mind saying this is all seriously stressing me out.
马克回答说他身上只有40美元，当那名男子接受了这么少的一笔钱时，他感到很惊讶。尽管心存疑虑，马克还是允许那名男子跟着他开车去车库。他在给塔布拉侦探的电子邮件中描述道：“当我们到达车库时，那种他杀的迹象几乎消失了，我从他身上感觉到了一种诡异的气息。”这名男子显然急着离开，把马自达的钥匙、行驶证和保险单交给了马克，然后就匆忙离开了。马克很快意识到这辆车是手动挡的，而他根本不会开手动挡，于是他让他的朋友乔斯把马自达开走并存放起来。马克在电子邮件的结尾写道：“我不介意直说，这一切真的让我压力山大。”
Identity theft is the first concern. My home being compromised is now another one, and we're strongly considering getting an active security system installed next week. I feel violated and angry that anyone was ruining around in my personal stuff without my knowledge, and now I'm greatly worried that they likely know where I live. My car has a distinctive appearance and an easily identifiable custom plate, and I'm wondering if this fellow who pawned the car off on me had seen mine before and might have been waiting for me or following me. I just don't know anymore. He could have been the person who broke into my car as well. There's a hundred different scenarios rushing through my head right now, and I'm not a fan of any of them. Detective Tabla shared Mark's email with his colleagues.
身份盗窃是首要担忧。我的家遭到侵入现在成了另一个担忧，我们正在认真考虑下周安装一个活跃的安全系统。有人在不知情的情况下把我的个人物品翻了个底朝天，这让我感到被侵犯和愤怒，现在我非常担心他们很可能知道我住在哪里。我的车外观独特且有容易识别的个性化车牌，我在想，这个把车死乞白赖推销给我的家伙是不是以前见过我的车，可能一直在等我或跟踪我。我真的不知道该怎么办了。他也可能是那个砸了我车的人。现在有一百种不同的剧本在我脑海里飞驰，而我一个也不喜欢。塔布拉侦探将马克的电子邮件分享给了同事们。
The odd stories only served to heighten their suspicions and take a closer look at the director. 29-year-old Mark Twitchell lived with his wife, Joss, and their eight-month-old daughter in a home they had purchased the previous year. Joss had insisted on the move as shared loathe to their previous neighborhood and threatened that their marriage might not last should they remain there. Mark got a mortgage to secure a new split-level home with a white picket fence in the Riverside District of St. Albert. Joss was Mark's second wife. The couple had met through an online dating service and married in 2006. By 2008, their relationship was strained and they were sleeping in separate bedrooms. Joss was unhappy about Mark's filmmaking efforts, which took up a large amount of his time for little financial gain.
这些离奇的故事非但没有打消疑虑，反而加剧了他们的怀疑，让他们决定更仔细地审视这位导演。29岁的马克·特维特切尔与妻子乔斯（Joss）以及他们八个月大的女儿住在他们前一年购买的房子里。乔斯坚持要搬家，因为他们都极度厌恶之前的社区，并威胁说如果继续呆在那里，他们的婚姻可能就维持不下去了。马克申请了房贷，在圣阿尔伯特（St. Albert）的河畔区（Riverside District）买下了一栋带白色栅栏的新错层住宅。乔斯是马克的第二任妻子。两人通过网络交友服务相识，并于2006年结婚。到2008年时，他们的关系已经很紧张，开始分房睡了。乔斯对马克的电影制作工作很不满，因为这占据了他大量的时间，却几乎没有什么经济回报。
It was part of Mark's identity. He was a regular cosplayer dressing up in costumes as Wolverine, Predator, and nearly every major Star Wars character while attending sci-fi and fantasy conventions where he took photos with the stars of his favorite series. One particularly elaborate costume of the Transformer Bumblebee won him over $3,000 in prizes for Radio Halloween Contests. He later sold it for a substantial amount. But his obsession came at the expense of his family, so Joss insisted they start attending couples therapy. Mark also agreed to weekly one-on-one sessions with a psychiatrist, and it seemed as though they were working. Despite their problems, Mark regarded Joss as a wonderful mother to their daughter, whom he believed was exceptionally adorable. On Monday, October 20, Mark Twitchell visited the Edmonton Police Service headquarters for a second interview.
这是马克身份的一部分。他是一个狂热的影视服装扮演者（Cosplayer），在参加科幻和奇幻大会时，会打扮成金刚狼、铁血战士以及几乎所有主要的《星球大战》角色，并在会上与他最喜欢的系列的明星合照。其中一套特别精致的“变形金刚大黄蜂”服装为他赢得了超过3000美元的广播万圣节比赛奖金。他后来以很高的价格把它卖掉了。但这种痴迷是以牺牲他的家庭为代价的，因此乔斯坚持他们开始进行夫妻心理治疗。马克还同意每周与精神病医生进行一次一对一的会谈，情况似乎有所改善。尽管存在种种问题，马克仍然认为乔斯是一个伟大的母亲，对他们的女儿疼爱有加，他觉得女儿异常可爱。10月20日星期天，马克·特维特切尔第二次前往埃德蒙顿警察局总部接受讯问。
It was performed by the forces star interrogator Bill Clark, known as the Pip Bull, a 30-year veteran detective skilled in the old-school style of grilling suspects. Mark acknowledged his legal right to have a lawyer present, but deemed it unnecessary. Every facet of Mark's story was probed, including his encounter with the unknown man who sold him a Mazda 323 for $40. He recalled the seller had a Celtic knot tattooed on his neck about three inches in diameter. The Mazda was later located in the possession of Mark's friend and crew member Joss, and confirmed to be Johnny Ultinger's vehicle. Detective Clark switched gear and changed his line of questioning, narrowing his focus on Johnny Ultinger. He pressed Mark, asking him questions like, What do you think happened? Do you think somebody has done something to harm him? Do you think he's really missing?
这次审讯由该局的王牌审讯专家比尔·克拉克（Bill Clark）主持，他被称为“斗牛犬”，是一位拥有30年经验的侦探，擅长老派的严厉盘问风格。马克承认了自己有权请律师在场的法律权利，但他认为没有必要。马克故事中的每一个方面都受到了盘问，包括他遇到那个以40美元向他出售马自达323的陌生男子的遭遇。他回忆说，那个卖家脖子上有一个直径约三英寸的凯尔特结纹身。这辆马自达后来在马克的朋克兼剧组人员乔斯那里被找到，并被证实确实是强尼·阿尔廷格的座驾。克拉克侦探转换了方向，改变了审讯路线，将焦点缩小到强尼·阿尔廷格身上。他向马克施压，问他诸如以下的问题：“你认为发生了什么？你认为有人做了什么伤害他的事吗？你觉得他是真的失踪了吗？”
Mark's response to which was that he didn't know. When asked, How do you think the results of this investigation are going to come out on you? He replied, Well, positively, I would think. I've been trying to tell you guys everything that I know. The bombardment of questions continued, leading into the possibility Johnny had met with foul play and Mark's opinions of the person who would carry out such a crime. Mark believed the perpetrator should go to prison with no mercy. When asked point blank if he had any involvement in Johnny's disappearance, Mark responded, No. Detective Clark continued to apply pressure, but Mark remained firm. After a short break at the interrogation's two and a half hour point, Detective Clark explicitly accused Mark of being involved,
对此，马克的回答是他不知道。当被问及：“你认为这次调查的结果对你会有什么影响？”他回答：“嗯，我想会是积极的。我一直在努力告诉你们我所知道的一切。”狂轰滥炸般的提问仍在继续，并引申到强尼可能遭遇不测的可能性，以及马克对实施这种犯罪的人的看法。马克认为凶手应该毫无怜悯地进监狱。当被直截了当地问及他是否参与了强尼的失踪时，马克回答：“没有。”克拉克侦探继续施加压力，但马克态度依然强硬。在讯问进行到两个半小时进行短暂休息后，克拉克侦探明确指控马克参与其中，
stating that detectives had since spoken with residents in Mill Woods, who reported seeing Mark changed the lock on the garage a week and a half earlier. Furthermore, the oil drum he had purchased to use at the site as a garbage can was known in the industry as a burn barrel and contained the charred remnants of a pair of eyeglasses which Johnny was known to wear. Mark appeared rattled, but continued to deny the allegations and eventually asked if he was free to go. With no hard evidence, Detective Clark was forced to release Mark, who shrugged and nodded when told his car was being seized as part of a search warrant. Detective Clark told him, It's gonna eat at you. If you're a normal person, it's gonna eat at you. Mark replied, You'd be surprised what I can live with. After his interrogation, Mark Twitchell finally engaged the services of a lawyer. The following day, police were granted permission to search his home and vehicle.
并表示侦探们此后与米尔伍兹的居民进行了交谈，居民们报告说看到马克在一个半星期前更换了车库的锁。此外，他为现场作为垃圾桶而购买的油桶在业内被称为焚烧桶，里面装着一副据信是强尼常戴的眼镜的烧焦残骸。马克显得有些慌乱，但继续否认这些指控，并最终询问自己是否可以离开。由于没有确凿证据，克拉克侦探被迫释放了马克。当被告知他的车将作为搜查令的一部分被扣押时，马克耸了耸肩并点了点头。克拉克侦探对他说：“这会折磨你的。如果你是个正常人，这会折磨死你的。”马克回答：“你对我的承受能力会感到惊讶的。”讯问结束后，马克·特维特切尔终于聘请了一名律师。第二天，警方获准搜查他的家和车。
In Mark's Pontiac, they found a half empty jerrycan of petrol and a Toshiba brand laptop covered in Spider-Man stickers, which appeared to be stained with blood. Similar staining was discovered on the upholstery in the trunk and on an 8-inch long hunting knife. There were cryptic instructions written on post-it notes such as, ship phone wallets on, return address of victim, destroy wallet contents, and kill room clean sweep. And roughly drawn maps, with one marking a path from Mark's home district of St. Albert to the crossroads near Johnny Yoltinger's apartment. In the back seat was a paperback from author Jeff Lindsey's darkly dreaming Dexter book series, which depicts the fictitious double life of Dexter Morgan. In his daily life, Dexter maintained a normal facade as a forensic blood spatter analyst. Privately, he was a vengeful serial killer who targeted individuals that were harmful to society.
在马克的庞蒂亚克汽车里，警方发现了一桶半满的汽油和一台贴有蜘蛛侠贴纸的东芝（Toshiba）牌笔记本电脑，该电脑上似乎沾有血迹。在后备箱的内饰上以及一把8英寸长的猎刀上也发现了类似的血迹。便利贴上写着晦涩的指令，例如：“寄出手机钱包，写上受害者的回信地址，销毁钱包内容，以及清理谋杀现场。”还有草率绘制的地图，其中一张标出了从马克位于圣阿尔伯特（St. Albert）的家到强尼·阿尔廷格公寓附近十字路口的路线。后座上放着一本作家杰夫·林德斯（Jeff Lindsay）的黑色惊悚小说《嗜血法医》（Darkly Dreaming Dexter）系列平装书，书中描绘了德克斯特·摩根（Dexter Morgan）虚构的双重生活。在日常生活中，德克斯特伪装成一名普通的法医血迹分析师。私下里，他是一个复仇心切的连环杀手，专挑那些对社会有害的人下手。
He went to great lengths to conceal his crimes, restraining his victims and dismembering their bodies in rooms covered in plastic before dumping their remains at sea. Luminol used throughout the Mills Wood garage exposed a large patch on the floor and several spatters on the wall. Similar spots were found on an open bottle of ammonia that Mark had purchased but denied using, as well as several other incriminating items, including a long metal table, various knives, scissors, and saws, as well as a selection of butcher tools that were part of a heavy-duty carving kit, including knives, shears, forks, and a rib-spreading device. The coiled end of a metal pipe appeared to contain traces of blood and tissue. Detectives spoke with Mark's friends and associates, some of whom suggested the situation might be a publicity stunt to promote House of Cards, describing Mark as someone who would do anything to get noticed.
他想方设法掩盖自己的罪行，将受害者捆绑并在铺满塑料的房间里肢解他们的尸体，然后将残骸抛入大海。在米尔伍兹车库各处使用的鲁米诺（Luminol）试剂显现出地板上的一大片区域和墙壁上的几个血迹斑点。在一瓶马克买过但否认使用过的开封氨水上也发现了类似的斑点，此外还有其他几件 incriminating（ incriminating / 罪证物品），包括一张长金属台、各种刀具、剪刀和锯子，以及一套作为重型雕刻工具组成部分的屠宰工具，包括刀具、剪子、叉子和扩张肋骨的器械。一段盘绕的金属管末端似乎含有血迹和组织痕迹。侦探们与马克的许多朋友和同事进行了交谈，其中一些人暗示这可能是一场宣传《纸牌屋》的噱头，并将马克描述为一个为了出名什么都做得出来的人。
Others had received an email from Mark, discouraging them from speaking with police. With the evidence mounting against him, a covert surveillance team watched Mark 24-7 and calls to and from his cell phone were monitored. However, nothing in his behaviour aroused suspicion. Motives remained a mystery, as their prime suspect appeared to be an ordinary family man who had no history with or connection to Johnny Ultinger. Meanwhile, investigators searched police records from the Mills Woods area and its surrounds for anything that could be connected to their case. They learned of a peculiar report made earlier that month on Friday, October 3, wherein a couple witnessed a man referred to as Frank, being accosted by an individual sporting a hockey mask. Investigators working the Ultinger case considered the possibility the couple had encountered Johnny, but the incident occurred a week before his date with Jan. The laptop found in Mark Twitchell's car was examined, with experts recovering a deleted text file titled SK Confessions.
其他人则收到了马克的电子邮件，劝阻他们不要与警察交谈。随着针对他的证据越来越多，一支秘密监视小组对马克进行了24小时的全天候监视，他的手机通话也受到了监控。然而，他的行为中没有任何引起怀疑的地方。动机仍然是个谜，因为他们的主要嫌疑人看起来像是一个普通的顾家好男人，与强尼·阿尔廷格没有任何历史交集或联系。与此同时，调查人员搜查了米尔伍兹地区及其周边的警察记录，寻找任何可能与他们的案件有关的线索。他们得知了当月初（10月3日星期五）发生的一起奇怪的报案，当时一对夫妇目睹了一个被称为“弗兰克”的男子遭到一个戴着曲棍球面具的个人的纠缠。调查阿尔廷格案的调查人员考虑了这对夫妇可能遇到了强尼的可能性，但该事件发生在强尼与简约会的一周前。在马克·特维特切尔的车里发现的那台笔记本电脑经过了检查，专家们恢复了一个名为《SK自白》（SK Confessions）的已删除文本文档。
The 45-page document read like a personal diary and began with the following disclaimer. This story is based on true events. The names and events were altered slightly to protect the guilty. This is the story of my progression into becoming a serial killer. The author explained that his inability to feel empathy had made him an expert at lying and deception. By age 30, he fantasised about being a serial killer who not only got away with murder, but profited financially from his crimes. He initially planned to prey on married men who were seeking to have affairs, stating, In one way, I'd be taking out the trash, doling out justice to those who on some level deserved what they got. But after analysing the risks, he decided to instead target single men in their 30s looking for love, as he believed they would have expendable income and be easily seduced.
这份长达45页的文件读起来就像是一份个人日记，开头有以下免责声明。本故事改编自真实事件。为了保护有罪之人，人名和事件作了轻微修改。这就是我一步步蜕变成连环杀手的历程。作者解释说，他缺乏同理心，这使他在撒谎和欺骗方面成了专家。到了30岁时，他幻想自己成为一个连环杀手，不仅能逍遥法外，还能从自己的犯罪行为中获得经济利益。他最初计划以那些寻求婚外情的已婚男子为猎物，并写道：“从某种意义上说，我是在清理垃圾，对那些在某种程度上罪有应得的人执行正义。”但在分析了风险之后，他决定转而将目标锁定在30多岁寻找爱情的单身男性身上，因为他相信这些人有可支配收入而且很容易被诱惑。
Moreover, as these men typically lived alone, their disappearances wouldn't be detected immediately. The author researched and planned each step methodically. He wanted his murder weapon to be simple, elegant and beautiful, and chose a well-crafted hunting knife with an 8-inch blade that he found at a military surplus store. A hunter's game processing kit containing tools designed to butcher large animal carcasses provided him a clean way to dismember bodies. He described finding the perfect location to carry out his crimes. A quote, double-detached garage for rent in the south of the city, tucked away in a quiet neighbourhood on a lot with a house occupied by tenants who couldn't even read English, much less speak it. Once his so-called little workshop of horrors was ready, the killer crafted online dating profiles to procure victims, first downloading an IP blocker so nothing could be traced back to him. He decided to carry out his murders on Fridays when he was supposed to be at a psychiatrist appointment, ensuring his wife would be none the wiser.
此外，由于这些人通常独居，他们的失踪不会被立即察觉。凶手有条不紊地研究并计划了每一个步骤。他希望自己的凶器简单、优雅而精美，于是选择了一把在军品店找到的、做工精良、刀刃长8英寸的猎刀。一套用来宰杀大型动物尸体的猎人野味处理工具为他提供了一种干净利落地肢解尸体的方法。他描述了寻找实施犯罪的完美地点的过程。原话：“城南有一处待租的独立双车库，坐落在一个安静的社区里，旁边房子的租客甚至连英文都不认识，更不用说会说了。”一旦他所谓的“恐怖小作坊”准备就绪，凶手便开始虚构网络交友资料来物色受害者，他先是下载了一个IP拦截器，这样就没有任何痕迹能追查到他。他决定在周五实施谋杀，因为那天他本该去见心理医生，以此确保他的妻子绝不会起疑。
Quote, Just not in the way she quite expected. The weekend also provided him time to clean and ensured his victim's disappearance initially went unnoticed as, quote, Most people are not hard and fast expected to be anywhere on the weekend. The author's first victim was a man he referred to as Frank, whom he'd lured to the garage after masquerading as an attractive blonde woman online. His second victim, Jim, arrived while preparations were still underway, forcing the killer to get him to leave. Later that night, Jim messaged his date again, still interested in getting together. Now ready, the killer invited him back to the garage.
引用：“只是结果并非她所预料的那样。”周末也为他提供了清理的时间，并确保受害者的失踪最初没有引起注意，因为原话：“大多数人周末并不被死板地要求非得出现在什么地方。”凶手的第一个受害者是一个被他称为弗兰克的男子，他伪装成一个有吸引力的金发美女，在网上将此人诱骗到了车库里。他的第二个受害者吉姆在准备工作仍在进行时就到了，这迫使凶手想方设法让他离开。那天晚些时候，吉姆再次给他的“约会对象”发了信息，表示仍然有兴趣聚聚。此时已经准备就绪的凶手邀请他回到了车库。
In the story, the killer received a call from his wife, Tess, just as he was finishing up dismembering his victim. He told his wife he was at the gym, but had to improvise when she pointed out that it closed an hour earlier, telling her he was at another gym in a different part of town. Investigators noted that the name Tess rhymed with the name of Mark Twitchell's wife. The story concluded with the killer using Jim's keys to access his apartment, which was described exactly like Johnny's. He took cash from a dresser and a few other items of interest, including a printer and a laptop. He was pleased to discover the device was still logged in to Jim's email and social media accounts. Quote, I couldn't have had an easier time.
在故事中，凶手刚刚完成对受害者的肢解，就接到了妻子苔丝的电话。他告诉妻子自己在健身房，但当妻子指出健身房一小时前就关门了时，他不得不临场应变，改口说自己在城里另一个地方的另一个健身房。调查人员注意到，苔丝（Tess）这个名字与马克·特维切尔（Mark Twitchell）妻子的名字押韵。故事的结尾是，凶手用吉姆的钥匙进入了他的公寓，这里的描述和强尼的公寓一模一样。他从梳妆台拿走了现金和一些其他感兴趣的物品，包括一台打印机和一台笔记本电脑。令他高兴的是，这台设备仍然登录着吉姆的电子邮箱和社交媒体账号。原话：“我从来没这么轻松过。”
I changed the auto response on his email to say he had decided to run away with the woman he hooked up with on Friday to go on a two month vacation to the Caribbean. Armed with this new evidence, detectives visited Mark Twitchell's home and confiscated a number of items, including several swords, a box for a stung baton, sales receipts for a butcher knife and handcuffs, an air pistol with baby blue pellets, and draft designs for a metal chair and table. A search of the basement office uncovered a black hockey mask featuring three gold stripes and a cut out chin. It was sitting on a pile of clothes near Mark's computer, which they also seized. There appeared to be blood stains on a pair of his jeans and a sweatshirt. There were also burned DVD copies of the second season of popular television series Dexter based on the darkly dreaming Dexter books. Mark Twitchell's wife, Jess, informed detectives that her husband was having an affair with an ex-girlfriend named Tracy, whom he'd met at college in 1997.
我把他邮箱里的自动回复改成了：他决定和周五勾搭上的那个女人私奔，去加勒比海进行为期两个月的度假。带着这些新证据，侦探们搜查了马克·特维切尔的家，并没收了许多物品，包括几把剑、一个电击警棍的包装盒、一把屠夫刀和手铐的购物小票、一把带有婴儿蓝弹丸的气枪，以及一张金属桌椅的设计草图。对地下室办公室的搜查发现了一个黑色曲棍球面具，上面有三道金色条纹和镂空的下巴。它放在马克电脑附近的一堆衣服上，电脑也被警方扣押了。他的几条牛仔裤和一件运动衫上似乎有血迹。还有第二季热门电视剧《嗜血法案》（基于《暗黑梦魇》系列小说）被烧录的DVD副本。马克·特维切尔的妻子杰丝（Jess）告诉侦探，她的丈夫与一个名叫特蕾西（Tracy）的前女友有染，两人于1997年在大学相识。
At the time, he had lied to Tracy about his age and background and convinced her to date him, even helping design her three inch Celtic cross tattoo. But she ended the relationship after uncovering his deception. The pair reconnected in the fall of 2008, with Mark concealing their daytime trists by telling his wife he was at work. Jess believed her husband was working through his issues during psychiatrist appointments on Friday evenings. But when she phoned Mark on the night of Friday, October 10, he claimed he was at a gym that she knew to be closed at the time. He clarified he was at their old gym, which stayed open later. She couldn't recall what time he returned home, but spent most of the following day with him, noting his mood was normal and he was, quote, easygoing, kind of relaxed. Jess revealed their marital problems began after a conversation in September, during which Mark revealed that he was unsure if he could feel empathy.
当时，他对特蕾西谎报了自己的年龄和背景，并说服她与自己交往，甚至帮她设计了那个三英寸大小的凯尔特十字架纹章。但当特蕾西发现他的骗局后，便结束了这段关系。2008年秋天，两人重新取得了联系，马克通过告诉妻子自己在上班来掩饰他们的白天偷情。杰丝以为她的丈夫是在周五晚上的心理医生预约期间解决自己的心理问题。但当她在10月10日星期五晚上给马克打电话时，马克声称他在一家她知道当时已经关门的健身房。他解释说，他在他们以前的那家营业时间更晚的健身房。她记不清他是什么时候回家的，但随后的吉日大多和他在一起，她注意到他的情绪很正常，而且原话：“随和，有点放松。”杰丝透露，他们的婚姻问题始于9月份的一次谈话，当时马克透露他很不确定自己是否有同理心。
In an effort to understand, Jess told the story of a woman who mistakenly left her baby in the car, resulting in its death. As a mother herself, Jess expressed a great deal of empathy for the woman, but Mark felt nothing. This upset Jess, who suggested he go to therapy. Mark's apathy appeared to be an ongoing issue, as he's first married gendered with divorce papers, citing his extreme and repeated mental cruelty. A document on Mark Twitchell's computer titled, Profile of a Psychopath, appeared to be a self-evaluation against traits listed in the DSM-4, a manual used to help diagnose mental health disorders. In the document, Mark detailed his efforts to deceive those around him, including telling people he was at work when he was really spending his time in cafes. He had falsified documents to obtain a mortgage, which he paid off using money investors had supplied for his films. He described the psychological torture he had inflicted on his wives, manipulating them to believe his infidelity was all in their heads.
为了理解这一点，杰丝讲了一个女人不小心把婴儿忘在车里导致其死亡的故事。作为一名母亲，杰丝对那个女人表达了极大的同理心，但马克却无动于衷。这让杰丝很心烦，她建议马克去看心理医生。马克的冷漠似乎是一个长期存在的问题，因为他的第一任妻子曾以他极端且反复的精神虐待为由向他提出过离婚文件。马克电脑上一份名为《精神病态者的档案》的文件，似乎是针对DSM-4（一本用于帮助诊断精神健康障碍的手册）中列出的特质进行的自我评估。在这份文件中，马克详细描述了自己欺骗身边人的努力，包括告诉别人自己在上班，而实际上他把时间都花在了咖啡馆里。他伪造文件来获得抵押贷款，并用投资者为他的电影提供的资金将其还清。他描述了对妻子们实施的精神折磨，操纵她们相信他的不忠纯粹是她们的幻觉。
When Jess caught him logged into a dating website, Mark claimed he had been hired to write an article about it and set up an elaborate series of fake email correspondence, and even hired an actor to play the role of the article's editor in an attempt to maintain the ruse. Another document investigators downloaded from Mark's computer was the screenplay for House of Cards. It detailed the story of Roger, a family man lured to a garage under the guise of meeting a woman he had connected with on an infidelity dating website. Once there, he's confronted by a man, quote, dressed in a large black PVC apron with gloves and sporting a black street hockey mask with the yellow streaks across it painted to look like a bear claw scratch with the mouth cut out. Roger is then tortured, murdered and dismembered by the masked man. After the gory kill scene, the script cut to a suburban house in a twist ending that revealed the killer was a writer, quote.
当杰丝发现他登录了一个约会网站时，马克声称自己是受雇写一篇关于该网站的文章，并精心编造了一系列假电子邮件往来，甚至雇了一个演员来扮演文章编辑的角色，企图维持这个骗局。调查人员从马克的电脑里下载的另一份文件是《纸牌屋》的剧本。它详细讲述了一个故事：一个顾家的男人罗杰，在婚外情交友网站上结识了一个女人，并在见面幌子的诱骗下来到了一个车库。一到那里，他就被一个男人迎面拦住，原话：“身穿一件带有手套的大号黑色PVC围裙，戴着一个黑色街头曲棍球面具，上面画着黄色的条纹，看起来像熊爪抓痕，嘴部被挖空。”接着，罗杰被这个戴面具的男人折磨、谋杀并肢解。血腥的杀戮场景结束后，剧本切换到一个郊区住宅，并以一个反转结局揭示凶手是一名作家，原话。
He closes Microsoft Word and a website showing the inside workings of a female profile on a cheetah's dating site is the last thing to shut down. He puts the laptop into his carrying case and leans over to close a duffel bag containing gloves, a stun gun and a black mouthless hockey mask with yellow streaks on it. The screenplay's final line was, It's true when they say the best way to succeed is to write what you know. The actor who played the deranged murderer in Mark's short film was identified as Robert Barnsley, who told police he had fun on set and enjoyed playing a serial killer. Chris Hewitt played Roger and recalled feeling uneasy during filming due to the use of real weapons on set, including a stun baton, knives and a samurai sword. DNA swabs taken from Johnny Yeltinger's cutlery, cups, razors and nail clippers were compared with forensic evidence found on the various items belonging to Mark Twitchell, returning a match. On October 31, the director was arrested and charged with the first degree murder of Johnny Yeltinger.
他关闭了微软Word，最后关闭的是一个显示猎豹交友网站上某个女性资料内部运作的网页。他把笔记本电脑放进手提包，俯身拉上了一个行李袋的拉链，里面装有手套、电击枪以及一个带黄色条纹、没有嘴部的黑色曲棍球面具。剧本的最后一句话是：“人们说成功最好的方法是写你所知道的事，这句话千真万确。”在马克的短片中扮演变态杀手的演员被辨认为罗斯·巴恩斯利（Robert Barnsley），他告诉警察他在片场玩得很开心，很享受扮演连环杀手。克里斯·休伊特（Chris Hewitt）饰演罗杰，他回忆说，由于片场使用了真正的武器（包括电击警棍、刀具和武士刀），他在拍摄过程中感到很不舒服。从强尼·耶尔廷格的餐具、杯子、剃须刀和指甲刀上提取的DNA拭子，与在马克·特维切尔名下的各种物品上发现的法医证据进行了比对，结果完全吻合。10月31日，这位导演被捕，并被指控一级谋杀强尼·耶尔廷格。
Investigators believed SK Confessions and the House of Cardscript to be admissions of guilt, but because Mark could argue both were works of fiction, they needed to prove the events outlined had actually occurred. SK Confessions referred to a victim named Jim, who police were certain was Johnny Yeltinger, but had also told of the author's first victim, a man he called Frank. This name was also mentioned in the Mills Wood police report taken on Friday, October 3. Police suspected that Mark Twitchell might have other unidentified victims. This one is for you. We've teamed up with Airbnb to share more about how to be an Airbnb host because you could be sitting in the perfect Airbnb spot right now. If you have a spare bedroom, which also side note is such a fun way to meet new people from around the world, if you're hosting them, why not make some extra money off of it? Or if you're always traveling like I am, it's so easy to just Airbnb your whole place. I was out of town for four months out of the year last year with a vacant condo just sitting there not being used.
调查人员认为《SK自白》和《纸牌屋》剧本是认罪供词，但由于马克可以辩称这两者都是虚构作品，他们需要证明大纲中概述的事件确实发生过。.>《SK自白》提到一个名叫吉姆的受害者，警方确信此人就是强尼·耶尔廷格，但其中也讲述了凶手的第一个受害者，一个他称之为弗兰克的男人。这个名字也在10月3日星期五的米尔伍德警察局报告中被提及。警方怀疑马克·特维切尔可能还有其他未被确认身份的受害者。这一段是给你的。我们与Airbnb合作，分享更多关于如何成为Airbnb房东的信息，因为你现在可能就坐在完美的Airbnb黄金地段里。如果你有一间空置的卧室——顺便说一句，这也是结识来自世界各地的新朋友的一种非常有趣的方式——如果你在接待他们，为什么不从中赚取一些外快呢？或者如果你像我一样经常旅行，把你的整个房子都上架Airbnb是如此简单。去年一年我有一四个月不在城里，空置的公寓就那样闲置着不用。
And I've realized how easy it would be to make extra money in the side to cover all of my travel costs when I'm away just by becoming an Airbnb host. When I'm traveling the world, I almost exclusively stay in Airbnb because I like having access to a kitchen, feeling like I'm at home when I'm traveling, having all the stuff that you would normally have when you're at home. And I love the local recommendation guides that a lot of hosts provide. So you can just get to know the area that you're visiting from someone who's actually lived in it. I just used Airbnb actually in Tulum to stay at truly the most luxurious penthouse loft I've ever seen. It was such a vibe. The aesthetic was incredible. The service was fantastic. And I loved the privacy of it. Airbnb is such a smart way to use what you already have to generate more income, whether you're saving for a wedding or a big trip somewhere, or just trying to cover bills and possibly bump up your income. Your home might be worth more than you think. So find out how much at Airbnb.ca slash host.
并且我意识到，只要成为一名Airbnb房东，在离家期间通过兼职赚取额外收入来支付我所有的旅行费用是多么容易。当我环游世界时，我几乎只住在Airbnb，因为我喜欢可以使用厨房，旅行时有在家的感觉，并拥有你在家时通常会拥有的所有东西。而且我很喜欢很多房东提供的本地推荐指南。所以你可以通过一个真正住在那里的人来了解你正在访问的地区。事实上，我最近在图卢姆就使用过Airbnb，住进了我见过最奢华的顶层阁楼。那里的氛围太棒了。美学令人难以置信。服务太棒了。而且我很喜欢它的私密性。Airbnb是利用你现有的资源来创造更多收入的一种非常聪明的方式，无论你是为婚礼或某次大型旅行存钱，还是只是想支付账单并可能提高收入。你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。所以在 Airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。
He wrote, My kill room was perfectly prepped. Plastic sheeting taped together and around my table. A large green cloth screwed into the drywall ceiling to shield view of it from my guest's line of sight. And to shield me too, of course. I now stood but a few feet away from the front door which I had locked, of course. The plan was to wait in the shadow of my curtain until he approached the door and shock him with the stumb button followed by a sleeper hold that would sap away his consciousness so that I could tape him up and set him on my table. At the allotted time, Frank entered the garage through the half open roller door. Several pages recounted what happened next, an ensuing scuffle, the wounds the killer inflicted, how Frank managed to break free, and the killer's frustration when his victim flagged down a couple who didn't assist but provided an opportunity for him to escape. This retelling in SK Confessions and the matching statement provided by the couple who happened across the attack indicated that Frank was a real person.
他写道：“我的杀戮室已经完美准备就绪。塑料布用胶带粘合在一起，并固定在我的桌子周围。一块巨大的绿色布料用螺丝钉固定在干墙天花板上，以挡住客人的视线。当然，也是为了挡住我自己。”我现在距离前门只有几英尺远，当然，门我已经锁上了。计划是躲在窗帘的阴影里等待，直到他走近门前，用电击警棍电击他，接着用一个锁喉把手耗尽他的意识，这样我就可以把他用胶带捆起来放到我的桌子上了。在预定的时间，弗兰克通过半开的卷帘门进入了车库。几页纸叙述了接下来发生的事情：随后的冲突、凶手造成的伤口、弗兰克如何设法挣脱，以及当他的受害者拦下一对没有提供帮助、却为他提供了逃跑机会的夫妇时，凶手的沮丧。《SK自白》中的这种重述，加上偶然路过袭击现场的那对夫妇提供的相吻合的陈述，表明弗兰克是一个真实存在的人。
In an effort to find him, investigators went public with the story. Newly separated at age 33, Gilles Tetro was looking for love when he joined plenty of fish. In September 2008, he encountered the profile of a user called Spiderwebs, an attractive girl next door blonde in her 30s who was new to Edmonton and wanted to meet people. Gilles sent her a message and she responded immediately, introducing herself as Sheena. She invited him on a date and the pair scheduled to meet on Friday, October 3 for dinner and a movie. Gilles agreed to pick Sheena up, although she wouldn't provide an address or phone number citing safety reasons. Instead, she gave directions to her home that he could access through the property's detached garage. Gilles didn't tell anyone about their arrangement, making his way to Sheena's Millwoods property as soon as he finished work on the appointed date.
为了找到他，调查人员将这个故事公之于众。33岁的吉尔·泰特罗（Gilles Tetro）刚刚离异，在加入Plenty of Fish交友软件时正寻找着爱情。2008年9月，他遇到了一个网名为Spiderwebs的用户资料，那是一个30多岁的、有吸引力的邻家金发女孩，刚来到埃德蒙顿，希望能结识新朋友。吉尔给她发了一条消息，她立刻回复了，并介绍自己叫希娜（Sheena）。她邀请吉尔约会，两人定于10月3日星期五共进晚餐并看电影。吉尔同意去接希娜，尽管出于安全原因，她不肯提供地址或电话号码。相反，她给出了可以从该物业的独立车库进入她家的路线。吉尔没有把他们的安排告诉任何人，在约定日期的下班后，径直前往希娜位于米尔伍德的房产。
He parked in front of the garage and headed inside, reaching a rear door that led out into the yard. As he touched its handle, someone grabbed him from behind and repeatedly struck his head with a blunt object. Assuming he was being mugged, Gilles turned to face his attacker, who was sporting a black hockey mask with gold markings. The assailant pressed the batten-type weapon against Gilles, causing electrical currents to surge through his body. The taser had little impact and Gilles managed to swipe it away, at which point the masked man pulled a gun from his pocket. He ordered Gilles to get on the ground and fasten to duct tape over his eyes when he obeyed. When Gilles heard a jingling sound similar to that of a belt buckle, he decided to fight back. He staggered to his feet, ripped the duct tape from his eyes and grabbed his assailant's gun, only to discover it was made of plastic.
他把车停在车库前，走了进去，来到一扇通往院子的后门。当他触碰门把手时，有人从后面抓住了他，并用钝器反复击打他的头部。吉尔以为自己遭遇了抢劫，转过身去面对袭击者，袭击者戴着一个带有金色标记的黑色曲棍球面具。袭击者将电击棒状的武器压向吉尔，导致电流在他的体内激增。泰瑟枪几乎没有什么影响，吉尔设法把它拍开了，这时戴面具的男人从口袋里掏出了一枪。他命令吉尔趴在地上，并在听从指令时把胶带缠在眼睛上。当吉尔听到类似于皮带扣碰撞的叮当声时，他决定反击。他蹒跚着站起身来，扯掉眼上的胶带，抓住了袭击者的枪，却发现它是塑料做的。
Gilles scuffled with his attacker, who punched him in the head. Gilles managed to slip out of his jacket, freeing him from his attacker's grasp. He rolled under the garage door and tried to run, but his leg muscles were weak from the taser and he fell onto the gravel driveway. The attacker reached under the door, grabbed his legs, and started dragging Gilles back in. When he let go for a split second to duck beneath the door, Gilles stood and staggered down the alley towards a nearby walking path, where he encountered a couple walking their dog. Although his cries for help caused the couple to flee, Gilles was able to get to his car and escape. His adrenaline wore off on the drive home, so he pulled over and passed out. When he came to 15 minutes later, he continued home where he treated his wounds and rested.
吉尔与袭击者扭打起来，对方朝他头部猛击一拳。吉尔设法脱下夹克，从而摆脱了袭击者的控制。他滚到车库门下试图逃跑，但他的腿部肌肉因遭到电击而虚弱，摔倒在碎石车道上。袭击者把手伸进门下，抓住他的腿，开始把吉尔往回拖。当袭击者为了低头钻过车库门而松手零点几秒时，吉尔站起来，跌跌撞撞地顺着小巷跑向附近的一条步道，在那里他遇到了一对遛狗的夫妇。尽管他的呼救声导致这对夫妇逃跑了，但吉尔还是设法找到了自己的车并成功逃脱。在开车回家的路上，他的肾上腺素渐渐消退，于是他把车停在路边昏迷了过去。15分钟后醒来时，他继续开车回家，在那里处理了伤口并休息了。
Upon waking a few hours later, Gilles logged into his plenty of fish account to download the communications between himself and Sheena, only to discover her profile and messages had been deleted. The only evidence he had of their interactions were the directions she provided to the garage, which he had copied and pasted into a separate document. Gilles called his ex-wife and told her about his ordeal. She urged him to report it to authorities and he agreed, but by the next morning he felt embarrassed and ashamed. Over the following days, Gilles' pain subsided and he convinced himself the incident was likely just a botched mugging and nothing more serious. Friends and co-workers who heard about the incident and saw his injuries implored Gilles to speak to police, but he just wanted to move on. The following month, on Sunday, November 2, Gilles read an article about the murder of Johnny Altinger in the Edmonton Journal newspaper. In it, police appealed for the accused's first victim to come forward, and recognizing the similarities to his own ordeal, Gilles went to the Edmonton police station. His story matched the attack on Frank as described in SK Confessions, almost word for word. Gilles Tetro later wrote in his memoir, The One Who Got Away.
几个小时后醒来时，吉尔登录了他的Plenty of Fish账号，想要下载自己和希娜之间的聊天记录，却发现她的个人资料和消息都被删除了。他关于他们的互动的唯一证据，就是她提供的去车库的路线，他把这些路线复制并粘贴到了一个单独的文档中。吉尔打电话给前妻，把自己的遭遇告诉了她。她敦促他向当局报告，他答应了，但到第二天早上，他感到既尴尬又羞耻。在接下来的几天里，吉尔的疼痛消退了，他劝说自己这起事件可能只是一次拙劣的抢劫，并没有什么大不了的。听说这起事件并看到他受伤的朋友和同事恳求吉尔报警，但他只想继续生活。次月，即11月2日星期日，吉尔在《埃德蒙顿太阳报》上读到了一篇关于强尼·阿尔廷格谋杀案的文章。在文中，警方呼吁嫌疑人的第一个受害者主动现身，吉尔认出了这与他自己的遭遇相似，便来到了埃德蒙顿警察局。他的故事与《SK自白》中对弗兰克的袭击描述几乎一模一样。吉尔·泰特罗后来在回忆录《逃脱的人》中写道。
I realized that I should be the one that was killed. Worse, I started to think that if only I would have gone to the police, John Altinger might be alive. If I had just gone like I said I would, nobody would have been killed. Guilt overwhelmed me. Two days later, on November 5, Edmonton police received a series of chat logs from a woman named Renee from Cleveland, Ohio. She had been interacting with a Facebook account that featured an image of fictional killer Dexter Morgan as his profile picture. As a fan of the show, Renee hoped the profile belonged to actor Michael C. Hall, who portrayed the character in the television series. She came to learn it was actually run by an indie filmmaker called Mark, and their conversations grew sinister over time. When Renee shared her fantasy about cutting up her ex's new wife and drawing circles in her blood, Mark gave her detailed instructions on how to carry out the act and get away with it. He told her to build a kill room lined with plastic, just like Dexter, then lure her target in and disable her with a stung baton.
我意识到，被杀的人本该是我。更糟糕的是，我开始想，如果我早点报警，约翰·阿尔廷格可能还活着。如果我像自己说的那样去报警，就不会有人被杀了。内疚感将我淹没。两天后的11月5日，埃德蒙顿警方收到了来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰一个名叫蕾妮的女性的一系列聊天记录。她一直在与一个Facebook账号互动，该账号以虚构杀手德克斯特·摩根的形象作为头像。作为该剧的粉丝，蕾妮希望这个账号属于在电视剧中扮演该角色的演员迈克尔·C·霍尔。她后来得知，这个账号实际上是由一个名叫马克的独立电影制作人运营的，随着时间的推移，他们的对话变得越来越阴暗。当蕾妮分享她关于把前夫的新妻子分尸并在她的血中画圆圈的幻想时，马克向她提供了如何实施该行为并逃脱法律制裁的详细说明。他告诉她建立一个用塑料布铺好的杀戮室，就像德克斯特那样，然后把目标诱骗进来，用电击棒将其制服。
He advised Renee to wrap her victims' remains in duct tape, place them in extra-strength garbage bags, and incinerate the body. He also suggested pulverizing the jawbone and removing teeth and fingertips to avoid identification. In a message sent on October 5, two days after the botched attack on Jill Tetrow, Mark informed Renee that a stung baton was ineffective and a sturdy pipe would work better. He also told her, A hunter's game processing kit comes with everything you would need to cut the body into nice manageable pieces. On October 10, hours before Johnny Altinger disappeared, Mark wrote, Sorry this is so short, but I'm juggling six things right now, and it's time to shift down to five. Four days later, he explained,
他建议蕾妮用胶带包裹受害者的遗体，把他们放进超强垃圾袋中，并将尸体焚烧。他还建议把下颌骨粉碎，并拔掉牙齿和指尖以避免被认出。在10月5日（对吉尔·泰特罗的拙劣袭击发生两天后）发送的一条消息中，马克通知蕾妮，电击警棍效率低下，一根坚固的管子会更好用。他还告诉她：“猎人的野味处理工具包里包含了把尸体切成漂亮、易处理的肉块所需的一切。”10月10日，在强尼·阿尔廷格失踪几小时前，马克写道：“抱歉这么简短，但我现在正同时应付六件事，是时候把负担减到五件了。”四天后，他解释说：
This weekend I made the rounds to two family thanksgiving events, and I've also had something else keeping me busy. I'm really concerned about telling anyone because of the implications. Suffice it to say, I crossed the line on Friday, and I liked it. She last heard from him on October 27 via an email informing her there was a missing person's investigation, possibly a homicide, centered on the garage he used. However, he was confident police wouldn't find anything, and told her not to ask about the details. Adding, Of course, all my recent delves into the darker fiction don't look good in all of this. After police confirmed that the victim Frank in SK Confessions was Jill Tetrow, they were more certain than ever that Jim was Johnny Altinger, with the document revealing his fate on Friday October 10, 2008. The author disclosed that when Johnny returned to the garage later that night to meet his date, he cheerfully announced,
这个周末我赶了两场家庭感恩节活动，而且还有别的事让我忙得不可开交。考虑到其中的牵连，我真的很担心把这事告诉任何人。简而言之，我在周五越界了，而且我很喜欢这种感觉。她最后一次收到他的消息是在10月27日通过一封电子邮件，信中通知她有一场针对他使用的车库的失踪人口调查，可能是一起凶杀案。然而，他确信警察不会找到任何东西，并告诉她不要打听细节。他还补充道：“当然，我最近对黑暗小说的所有钻研在这件事上看起来都不太好。”在警方确认《SK自白》中的受害者弗兰克就是吉尔·泰特罗后，他们比以往任何时候都更加确信吉姆就是强尼·阿尔廷格，该文件透露了他于2008年10月10日星期五的命运。作者透露，当强尼当晚晚些时候回到车库去见他的约会对象时，他高高兴兴地宣布：
I guess I'm just a glutton for punishment. To which the author replied, You have no idea. The story continued, describing how the killer violently struck Johnny to the back of the head with a pipe. Quote, I could feel my predator self take over. That one single motion was the end all be all. I had committed now, and there was no going back. After enduring hours of beatings, Johnny offered money in exchange for freedom and the promise not to go to police. Instead, the killer removed his hunting knife from its sheath and stabbed Johnny multiple times before placing his body on the custom made metal table. He dismembered him using the Hunter's Game Processing Kit, an act he considered a relatively unexciting event that he made fun by talking and singing to himself.
我想我就是自讨苦吃。对此，作者回答道：你完全想象不到。故事继续描述了凶手如何用一根管子猛击强尼的后脑勺。原话：“我能感觉到我的捕食者本能在接管身体。那一个单一的动作是一切的终结。我已经犯下了罪行，再也无法回头了。”在忍受了数小时的殴打后，强尼提出用钱换取自由，并承诺不报警。相反，凶手将猎刀从刀鞘中拔出，多次刺向强尼，然后将他的尸体放在定制的金属桌上。他用猎人野味处理工具将其肢解，他认为这是一个相对平淡无奇的事件，他通过自言自语和唱歌来给自己找乐子。
He explained how he would have purchased an incinerator to destroy Johnny's remains, but the high cost forced him to make do with a steel barrel and a jerry can of gasoline. The killer placed the drum in his car and took it to his parents place in North Edmonton, where he set it alight in the centre of the yard. The story ended abruptly after the author realised that the body wouldn't completely burn. However, a file found on a desktop computer at Mark Twitchell's parents home appeared to be a continuation of the writings. The new text began. The sewer, of course, how obvious. No one ever goes down there. Following this revelation, police and city workers combed Mark's parents' property and inspected the surrounding sewer system, but found no evidence of Johnny alting his remains. Over the next 18 months, Mark remained in prison as his trial loomed, drawing pictures and writing stories to pass the time. The investigators had all but given up on recovering Johnny alting his body when shortly after 6pm on Thursday, June 3, 2010, homicide detectives were called to meet Mark and his lawyer at the Romance Centre.
他解释说，他本可以买一个焚化炉来销毁强尼的遗体，但高昂的成本迫使他只能用一个钢桶和一个汽油桶将就。凶手把铁桶放进车里，带到了他父母位于埃德蒙顿北部的住所，并在院子中央将其点燃。在作者意识到尸体无法完全烧毁后，故事戛然而止。然而，在马克·特维切尔父母家的一台台式电脑上发现的一个文件，似乎是这些文字的续集。新文本开始了。下水道，当然，多显而易见啊。根本没人会去那种地方。在这个发现之后，警察和城市工人梳理了马克父母的房产，并检查了周围的下水道系统，但没有找到强尼·阿尔廷格遗体的任何证据。在接下来的18个月里，随着审判的临近，马克一直被关在监狱里，靠画画和写故事来打发时间。调查人员几乎已经放弃了找回强尼·阿尔廷格尸体的希望，就在2010年6月3日星期四下午6点过后不久，凶杀案侦探被召集去浪漫中心会见马克和他的律师。
During the meeting, Mark passed the detectives a piece of paper that contained a map of North Edmonton and the words, location of John alting his remains. The map directed officers to an alleyway just one block from where police had carried out their search in November 2008. There, they peered through a sewer grate at what appeared to be two pieces of human remains below. Less than half of the bones of a human body were recovered, later confirmed to be those of Johnny alting her. Mark Twitchell's trial began the following year on Wednesday, March 16, 2011. The prosecution presented their case that Mark had lured strangers to his specially designed kill room, where he attacked them by replicating methods used by fictional serial killer Dexter Morgan, whom he was obsessed with. The SK Confessions document was an integral part of the prosecution's case, with detective Mark Anstey going through the document line by line and identifying 301 passages that likely occurred in real life. Many witnesses took the stand, including Trevor and Marissa, the couple who had interrupted the attack on Gilles Tetreux. Following their testimony, they met with Gilles to apologise for not assisting him, and he forgave them. The defense's major witness was Mark Twitchell himself. His responses were mostly dry and concise, but he became animated and excited when discussing his film projects. He described House of Cards as an ambitious and interactive project he called multi-format psychosis layering entertainment, or maple.
在会面期间，马克递给侦探一张纸，上面画着一张埃德蒙顿北部的地图，并写着“约翰·阿尔廷格遗体的位置”。地图指引警官们来到一条小巷，距离警方在2008年11月进行搜查的地方只有一个街区。在那里，他们透过一个下水道格栅，看到了下面似乎是两块人类遗骸的东西。回收的骨骼不到一大人体骨骼的一半，后被证实属于强尼·阿尔廷格。马克·特维切尔的审判于次年（2011年3月16日星期三）开始。控方陈述了他们的案情：马克将陌生人诱骗到他专门设计的杀戮室中，在那里通过复制他痴迷的虚构连环杀手德克斯特·摩根所使用的方法来袭击他们。《SK自白》文件是控方案情不可或缺的一部分，侦探马克·安斯特（Mark Anstey）逐行审阅了该文件，并确定了301处可能在现实生活中发生过的段落。许多证人出庭作证，包括特雷弗和玛丽莎，这对打断了对吉尔·泰特罗袭击的夫妇。他们的证词结束后，他们与吉尔见面，为没有协助他而道歉，吉尔原谅了他们。辩方的主要证人是马克·特维切尔本人。他的回答大多干巴而简洁，但当谈到他的电影项目时，他变得生动而兴奋。他将《纸牌屋》描述为一个雄心勃勃的交互式项目，他称之为“多格式精神病层叠娱乐”（简称枫树项目，maple）。
He wanted to build on the kind of buzz created by other experimental films such as The Blair Witch Project, which was marketed as being genuine-found footage rather than a professionally produced movie. Mark hoped to expand his serial killer short film into a feature, and after its release, he would pen a novel told from the perspective of the film's producer. The idea was to sow seeds of doubt as to whether the film was real or not. He began writing the novel, calling it SK Confessions, as a homage to horror and supernatural fiction author Stephen King. The third step would be to harness social media, creating posts from people who would allege to have almost been a victim of the hockey-mask killer themselves. Using a photo of a woman he had stolen from another plenty of fish profile, Mark searched for someone to serve this purpose and found Gilles Tetreux. Mark arranged the time for him to come to the garage, which he designed to resemble a kill room to provide the desired effect. He said he planned to fill Gilles in on his elaborate plan, but decided to switch it up by genuinely scaring him into thinking he was about to be murdered. He donned the hockey mask and used the stumb baton, claiming he knew the implement would not cause significant harm.
他希望借此延续其他实验电影（如《布莱尔女巫》）所创造的热度，该片被营销为真实找到的录像，而不是专业制作的电影。马克希望将他的连环杀手短片扩展为长片，上映后，他将以该片制片人的视角撰写一部小说。这个想法是为了播下怀疑的种子，让人分不清这部电影到底是真是假。他开始撰写这部小说，将其命名为《SK自白》，以此向恐怖和超自然小说作家斯蒂芬·金致敬。第三步是利用社交媒体，发布一些自称几乎成为曲棍球面具杀手受害者的人的帖子。马克使用了从另一个Plenty of Fish个人资料中盗取的一个女性照片，寻找能够充当这个角色的人，并找到了吉尔·泰特罗。马克安排了他来车库的时间，车库的设计类似于杀戮室以提供预期的效果。他说他原本计划向吉尔透露他精心策划的计划，但决定换一种方式，真真切切地吓唬他，让他以为自己要被谋杀了。他戴上曲棍球面具，使用了电击警棍，并声称他知道这个工具不会造成重大伤害。
The plan was always to let Gilles go, so that when the House of Cards movie and book were released, his experience with the hockey-mask killer would be convincing. Mark said he kept the mask, hoodie, baton and handcuffs because he figured it would be best to come clean if Gilles did report what had happened. The following week, he used the name Jen and scheduled a date with his next target, Johnny Altinger. Mark arrived at the garage at around 6pm on Friday, October 10, 2008, using his laptop to continue messaging Johnny, who showed up earlier than expected. Mark threw up the smokescreen that Jen was stuck in traffic and wouldn't be able to make it for at least 30 minutes, so Johnny left. He wondered whether he should reveal the truth to Johnny over email or in person, and ultimately invited him back, still posing as Jen. When Johnny returned, Mark informed him that there was no Jen and tried to explain his psychosis layering idea. Johnny was unhappy at having been duped and the two got into an argument.
这个计划一直是放吉尔走，这样当《纸牌屋》电影和书发行时，他与曲棍球面具杀手的经历就会显得很有说服力。马克说，他保留了面具、连帽衫、警棍和手铐，因为他琢磨着如果吉尔真的报警了，最好还是坦白交代。第二周，他用了“珍”这个名字，和他的下一个目标强尼·阿尔廷格预约了约会。2008年10月10日星期五晚上6点左右，马克到达了车库，用他的笔记本电脑继续给强尼发信息，强尼比预期来得早。马克释放烟雾弹，谎称珍被堵在路上，至少30分钟内赶不到，于是强尼就离开了。他琢磨着是通过电子邮件还是当面把真相告诉强尼，最终他还是以珍的身份再次邀请他过来。当强尼回来时，马克告诉他根本没有什么珍，并试图解释他的“精神病层叠”构想。强尼对自己被忽悠感到很不高兴，两人发生了争执。
Mark claimed that as he turned, Johnny kicked him in the lower back before grabbing a pipe and swinging it at him. Mark dodged the first couple of swings, but the third came down on his elbow. He wrestled the pipe from Johnny and hit him on the top of the head with it. As the fight continued, Mark grabbed a knife hoping Johnny would back off. Instead, he rushed forward and Mark stabbed him. Quote, It was just the sickest feeling ever. I just started to feel this wet sensation around the hand still holding the handle and I let go instinctively, and then I saw it sticking out of him.
马克声称，当他转身时，强尼踢了他的下背部，然后抓起一根管子向他挥来。马克躲过了前两下挥击，但第三下落在了他的肘部上。他从强尼手中抢过管子，用它砸向强尼的头顶。随着搏斗的继续，马克抓起一把刀，希望强尼能退缩。相反，强尼冲了过来，马克捅了他一刀。原话：“那真是一种最恶心、最糟糕的感觉。我刚开始感觉到握着刀柄的手周围有一种湿漉漉的感觉，本能地松开了手，然后我看到它从他身上戳了出来。”
Upon realizing Johnny was dying, Mark said, It's one of those things when I'm just stuck there and can't decide what to do. I'm just frozen by inaction. There's a war going on between screaming out in my head, call 911, but at the same time, how bad does this look? Take a look around. Look at what this place looks like. Mark said he panicked and decided to use his film set to, quote, Do things that had never been designed to do.
意识到强尼快要死了，马克说：“这就是那种让我卡在那里、不知该怎么办的情况。我直接被不作为给冻僵了。我脑子里有个声音在大喊‘快打911’，但与此同时，这看起来得多糟糕啊？看看四周。看看这地方现在是什么样。”马克说他慌了神，决定利用他的电影布景来做原话：“从来没想过要用来做的事情。”
From this point on, he agreed that the dismemberment, failed cremation and disposal of Johnny's body, as well as using his social media and email accounts to cover up his crime, had occurred as written in SK Confessions. However, he said the feelings described when cutting up the body were exactly the opposite of the truth. He felt weaker, not stronger, like he was carrying a heavy burden he would never be able to share. As for the messages Mark sent his Facebook friend Renee four days after Johnny's murder, in which he wrote, Suffice it to say, I crossed the line on Friday and I liked it. He insisted this was in reference to his affair with ex-girlfriend Tracy. In summary, Mark's attorney maintained that Johnny's death was accidental and in self-defense,
从这一点开始，他承认对强尼遗体的肢解、失败的火化和抛尸，以及利用他的社交媒体和电子邮件账号来掩盖他的罪行，都如《SK自白》中所写的那样发生了。然而，他说，在分尸时所感受到的情绪与事实完全相反。他感到的是虚弱，而不是强大，就像背负着一个他永远无法分享的沉重包袱。至于马克在强尼遇害四天后发给Facebook好友蕾妮的信息，他在信中写道：“简而言之，我在周五越界了，而且我很喜欢这种感觉。”他坚称这是指他与前女友特蕾西的婚外情。综上所述，马克的律师坚称强尼的死是意外且属于正当防卫，
adding that SK Confessions was a work of fiction, or at best, a fictionalized version of real events. The prosecution pointed out that Mark Twitchell's entire life was built on fantasy and lies, and that his testimony should be taken with a grain of salt. He lied to his wife, his girlfriend and friends, as well as Jill, Johnny, and the police. The prosecutor remarked that Mark's assertions that he only aimed to recruit strangers to help create an online urban legend were as ridiculous as the story about the $40 Mazda. On Tuesday, April 12, 2011, the jury found Mark Twitchell guilty of the first-degree murder of Johnny Altinger. In her victim impact statement, Johnny's mother, Alfreda, explained that Johnny's telephone company hadn't yet reassigned his number,
并补充说《SK自白》是一部虚构作品，或者充其量是真实事件的虚构化版本。控方则指出，马克·特维切尔的一生完全建立在幻想和谎言之上，他的证词应该大打折扣。他对他的妻子、女友和朋友，以及吉尔、强尼和警方都撒了谎。公诉人评论说，马克声称自己只是想招募陌生人来帮助创造一个网络都市传说的说法，就像那个关于40美元马自达汽车的故事一样荒谬。2011年4月12日星期二，陪审团裁定马克·特维切尔谋杀强尼·阿尔廷格的一级谋杀罪名成立。强尼的母亲阿尔弗雷达在受害者影响陈述中解释说，强尼的电话公司当时还没有重新分配他的号码，
so she constantly rang it just to hear his voicemail greeting. Quote, He was a pure joy as a child. It was an amazing journey watching him grow in every way and make his way through life. There are no words to describe the pain and feelings of horror one goes through. I can't imagine the fear, desperation and pain Johnny must have endured. As a mother, I feel I can't think about it without going over the edge. There is no joy in life. It has been ripped away from me. I fear this nightmare and my grief will continue until my dying day.
所以她经常给它打电话，只为了听听他的语音信箱问候语。原话：“他小时候是个纯粹的快乐源泉。看着他方方面面地成长，并在生活中摸索前行，这是一段神奇的旅程。没有任何言语可以形容一个人所经历的痛苦和恐惧感。我无法想象强尼当时一定承受了多少恐惧、绝望和痛苦。作为一个母亲，我觉得如果不崩溃的话，我根本无法去想这件事。生活中已经没有快乐可言了。这一切都被从我身边剥夺了。我担心这场噩梦和我的悲伤将一直持续到我生命的最后一刻。”
People have asked me if I wish there was still the death penalty and I must answer no. My wish is for the perpetrator of this unforgivable and terrific act to reflect on his actions and die a slow death every day of his life. In his statement, Gary Altinger wrote, I know my baby brother is never coming back. For justice to prevail, it would only be right that Mark Twitchell never see the light of day again. Mark Twitchell was sentenced to life in prison with a minimum of 25 years. Following the trial, Gary told the media of the grief his family had been exposed to over the previous weeks and years, stating that it was something no human being should ever feel.
人们曾问我是否希望仍然保留死刑，我的回答是没有。我的愿望是，这个不可饶恕的、可怕行为的肇事者能够反思自己的行为，并在他余生的每一天里体验缓慢死亡的痛苦。加里·阿尔廷格（Gary Altinger）在陈述中写道：“我知道我的小弟弟永远不会回来了。为了让正义得以伸张，唯一正确的结果就是马克·特维切尔再也见不到天日。”马克·特维切尔被判处终身监禁，不得假释期为25年。审判结束后，加里向媒体讲述了过去几周和几年里他的家人所遭受的悲伤，并表示这是任何人类都不应该感受到的。
Alfreda added that although there will never be closure, we will move on to the next step I think, start to heal, if that's possible. Mark Twitchell attempted to appeal his conviction on the grounds that extensive media coverage ruined any opportunity for a fair trial, but the appeal was abandoned in 2012. In May 2013, it was reported that Mark had purchased a television for his prison cell, which he used to catch up on every episode of Dexter that he had missed since his incarceration. Detective Mark Anstey believed the precautions taken by Johnny Altinger prior to his date with Jen had ultimately saved others. By sharing his plans and whereabouts with friends and emailing them the directions to the garage,
阿尔弗雷达补充说，尽管永远不会有真正的了结，但我想我们会进入下一个阶段，开始疗伤，如果这还有可能的话。马克·特维切尔曾试图以广泛的媒体报道毁掉了公平审判的机会为由对他的定罪提出上诉，但该上诉于2012年被撤销。2013年5月，据报道马克为他的牢房买了一台电视，他用它补完了自入狱以来错过的每一集《嗜血法案》。侦探马克·安斯特认为，强尼·阿尔廷格在与珍约会前采取的预防措施最终拯救了其他人。通过与朋友分享他的计划和行踪，并向他们发送车库的路线邮件，
he enabled police to swiftly identify Mark Twitchell as their prime suspect, ensuring he didn't have an opportunity to claim more victims. Detective Anstey told Johnny's mother, your son in a roundabout way was a hero. He definitely saved a lot of grief for other families. . There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他使警方能够迅速将马克·特维切尔确定为头号嫌疑人，从而确保他没有机会再残害更多受害者。安斯特侦探对强尼的母亲说：“你的儿子以一种迂回的方式成为了一个英雄。他绝对为其他家庭免去了许多悲伤。”本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。